hey this is presh talwalker
the Turkish University entrance exams
consist of two parts
first is a basic proficiency test that
about 3 million students take
then there are field proficiency tests
in different subjects
about 2 million students take these
tests and they can be quite challenging
in the last year the mathematics test
had an average score of about 7.6 out of
40 questions
that's only 20 percent of the questions
that are solved correctly
so let's look at one such question
let P of X be a fourth degree cortic
polynomial with real coefficients
for all real values of X the polynomial
satisfies the condition P of X is
greater than or equal to X
now suppose
P of 1 is equal to 1 P of 2 is equal to
4 and P of 3 is equal to 3.
what is the value of P of 4 equal to
this is translated and adapted from a
ayt exam and I thank Alp for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so this is much more challenging than it
looked at first to me
I thought you could just substitute in
the values for the polynomial get a
system of equations and solve for the
coefficients
but you only have three values for a
fourth degree polynomial so that's
insufficient information
we're going to have to rely on other
conditions given in the problem
so let's first Define a new polynomial Q
of x to be equal to P of x minus X
since P of X is greater than or equal to
x q of X will be greater than or equal
to zero
now since P of X is the fourth degree
polynomial
Q of X is p of x minus X so this will
also be a fourth degree polynomial
now let's solve for specific values of
the polynomial Q of x
Q of 1 is equal to P of 1 minus 1. we
were given that p of 1 is equal to one
so this is equal to one minus 1 which
equals zero Q of 2 is equal to P of 2
minus two we were given P of 2 is equal
to four so this equals four minus two
which equals two
finally Q of three is equal to P of 3
minus three we are given that p of 3 is
equal to three so this equals three
minus three which equals zero
so we now have three specific values of
the polynomial Q of x
so let's plot them to get a better
understanding of this polynomial
one value is one comma zero another
value is two comma two and a third value
is three comma zero
we know that Q of X is greater than or
equal to zero
now as X approaches Infinity that means
Q of X has to also approach positive
Infinity it can't go to negative
Infinity because Q of X is greater than
or equal to zero so we know the limiting
behavior on the right side of this graph
normally as X goes to negative Infinity
Q of X has to go to positive Infinity
so we also have the limiting behavior on
the left side of the graph
how does this information help us
well we know three particular points and
we know the limiting behavior and we
know that Q of X is a cortic
so can we have any other Roots a quartet
can have up to four roots
while the answer is no
so here's the reason why
so from the point one comma zero we know
on the left hand side we're going to
eventually have to go to positive
infinity and we know on the right hand
side we're going to have to go up to two
comma two
similarly for the point two comma 2 we
know we have to increase up to this
point then at some point around that
point or after it we're going to have to
go back down because we have to get down
to three comma zero
for the point three comma 0 the function
has to decrease to three comma zero and
then after that it's going to have to
increase
so what have we identified we have
identified three different turning
points or three different critical
points or three different local Minima
or Maxima so one point here another
Point here and another point will be in
the neighborhood of two comma two we
don't know it is exactly two comma two
but it'll be somewhere between one comma
zero and three comma zero
now since we have a cortic polynomial
it's derivative Q Prime of X will be a
cubic polynomial the degree will be
equal to 3.
so that derivative can have at most
three turning points so we've identified
these are the three critical points we
can't have any more so we can't have any
other roots in this polynomial
so we know that the graph has to
essentially connect the things we've
already drawn
so it's going to have to come down over
here then we're going to have to go up
to two comma 2 or somewhere around there
it'll have to come back down to three
comma zero and then it'll have to go off
to Infinity
so this is what Q of X is going to look
like it's a sketch we don't know exactly
in the middle what it's going to look
like but it'll look something like this
furthermore at one comma zero the graph
is bouncing off the x-axis and the same
thing goes for three comma zero so we
have double roots over here so we know
that x minus 1 will be a double Factor
so it'll be squared and the same thing
with x minus 3.
now where does that get us so Q of X
will be equal to some scaling factor a
multiplied by the square of x minus 1
multiplied by the square of x minus 3.
so we've completely factored the cortic
polynomial Q of X so All That Remains is
to solve for the scaling factor a
to do that we'll use the point two comma
2. so we will substitute in that Q of 2
is equal to 2 and we will substitute in
X is equal to 2.
now simplifying this we get that 2 is
equal to a
so we've solved for Q of x
now we know that Q of X is equal to P of
x minus X adding an X to both sides will
give that P of X is equal to Q of X Plus
X
so we've solved that P of X is equal to
2 multiplied by the square of x minus 1
multiplied by the square of x minus 3
plus X
so we solve for p of X and the only
thing that remains is to figure out the
value of P of 4. so we substitute in X
is equal to four
then we simplify this this is 2
multiplied by 3 squared multiplied by 1
squared plus four this all simplifies to
be 22 and therefore P of 4 is equal to
22 and that's the answer
to conclude the video I want to show a
review example of how you could actually
solve it on the test in a reasonable
amount of time
so here's the question let P of X be a
second degree quadratic polynomial with
real coefficients for all real values of
X the polynomial satisfies the condition
P of X is greater than or equal to 2x
Plus 1. if P of 1 is equal to 3 and P of
2 is equal to 8 what is the value of P
of negative one
so let's work this out we'll Define a
new polynomial Q of x to be P of x minus
the quantity 2x plus 1. this will be
greater than or equal to zero
now Q of 1 is equal to P of 1 minus 2
multiplied by one plus one so this is
all equal to zero
so we can now see that Q of X is a
quadratic polynomial we have one point
that's one comma zero and we know that Q
of X is greater than or equal to zero
we're going to have one Turning Point
here because it's a quadratic so the
graph will look something like this so X
is equal to 1 is a double root so Q of X
is equal to a scaling factor a
multiplied by the square of x minus 1.
we want to solve for a so we will now
substitute Q of 2. this is equal to P of
2 minus 2 times 2 plus 1. this works out
to be a minus 5 and that's equal to 3.
so we have that 3 is equal to a
multiplied by the square of 2 minus one
that means a is equal to 3. so we have q
of X is equal to 3 multiplied by the
square of x minus one
then P of X is equal to Q of X plus two
X plus one we substitute for Q of X and
then we just need to evaluate at X is
equal to negative one
so P of negative 1 is equal to 3
multiplied by the square of negative 1
minus 1 plus 2 times negative one plus
one and this all simplifies so that P of
negative one is equal to 11 and that's
the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time